welcome back to street talk unplugged
today we're going to be having a
conversation with leticia pacquiao from
the ai coffee break youtube channel but
just before that um i wanted to do a
little bit of housekeeping and briefly
discuss the symbolism debate which is
raging on twitter right now professor
gary marcus recently released an article
called deep learning is hitting a wall
um i think it was a very well written
and well researched article um actually
by the way i don't know whether you guys
have checked our merch store but we do
have a very special limited edition mug
uh paying homage to gary marcus i think
it's a little bit inappropriate so we'll
actually remove it within a week or so
but if you're quick you can you can
still order some but uh
[Music]
yeah come in coming back to what we were
saying
it does actually have some quite
provocative um statements in there such
as few fields have been more filled with
hype than artificial intelligence i mean
he gives plenty of examples of what he
perceives to be the failures of deep
learning for example gpt-3 suggesting
that people should commit suicide or
that bill gates invented covet 19. he
cites bender airtel's stochastic parrots
paper which argued that deep
learning-powered language models are a
bit like stochastic parrots they repeat
a lot and understand little
now a big part of the disagreement here
i think is that
um we should really be developing
intelligent models but there's no
consensus whatsoever
on what is meant by intelligence we just
recorded a show with uh dr pay wang
and we'll be releasing that very soon
but you know we were discussing the
definitional challenges
of intelligence he thinks that it should
mean adaptation with insufficient
knowledge and resources which i think is
is fascinating now pay thinks that many
researchers would rather pursue whatever
objective is fruitful
either in theory or in practice today
no matter whether it's labelled ai or
not and many of the definitions of
artificial intelligence are just
disliked by researchers not because
they're wrong but because they're not
useful
now this conception of intelligence
point actually seems to be the biggest
issue in my opinion this is the reason
why our friend francois charlay thinks
that deep learning won't work because in
his conception an intelligent system
must produce a new skill program which
is as small as possible yet generalizes
to many new situations and experience
space and he says that we need to
explicitly account for prize and
experience otherwise he says we would
only achieve the pilot trick of
intelligence because we'd be taking
shortcuts
now marcus says that insiders have long
known that the biggest problem in
artificial intelligence research is the
tests or the benchmarks that were used
to evaluate the systems
who would have thought it that
optimizing and evaluating models on
benchmarks reflective of task specific
skill
don't actually lead to actually
intelligent models
unfortunately the idea that we should
associate intelligence with the trivial
mapping between the inputs
and the behavioral outputs of an agent
ignoring the inner state like in the
turing test or the crystallized subset
of capabilities of a model rather than
how those capabilities manifested are
still pervasive
now gary is basically arguing that we
need to have a much deeper and more
nuanced understanding of human cognition
now um some people have said that
there's something inherently toxic
about this discussion
or that he's being subversive or overly
provocative or in the worst case that
he's been operating in bad faith somehow
i honestly don't think that's the case i
mean just read the article why it's
extremely well written and well
researched i do think he's a bit of a
troll to say that deep learning is
hitting a brick wall right um that's
ridiculous
there are some fundamental limitations
to deep learning depending on how you
frame intelligence into the discussion
as i just mentioned but that doesn't
mean that it isn't an incredibly
groundbreaking technology
right we can bash deep learning all day
long but it certainly has not hit a wall
and it's delivering mind-blowing results
every single day i mean just look at the
neural radiance fields for view
synthesis paper for example it's unreal
some folks have bemoaned that gary
hasn't suggested any better symbolic
alternatives other than the nethack
challenge near the end of last year
nethack is an ascii 2 rendered
single-player dungeon crawl game that is
perhaps the oldest and most difficult
computer game in history it's
procedurally generated with hundreds of
different entities and complex
environment dynamics presenting an
extremely challenging environment for
both current state-of-the-art
reinforcement learning agents
and humans
now the task was overwhelmingly won by a
symbolic approach gary said that he
suspected that the answer begins with
the fact that the dungeon is generated
afresh every single game which means you
can't simply memorize or approximate the
game board to win you need a reasonably
deep understanding of the entities in
the game and their abstract
relationships to one another
ultimately players need to reason about
what they can and cannot do in the
complex world
but anyway other than that gary didn't
really offer many examples of symbolic
dominance
other than his usual trick which is to
suggest that hybrid models like alpha
zero are in fact symbolic
but nobody likes to mention it i'll
discuss definitionals in a minute but i
actually don't think of alpha zero as
being a symbolic model or even a hybrid
model
i mean we could argue about semantics on
that but the apparent lack of symbolic
methods around today
i think this is a bit of a lack of
imagination
and the absence of evidence is not
evidence of absence
so let's not forget that connectionism
was shunned at one point but it quickly
became a darling once again
the moment it found a useful domain of
application you know which was catalyzed
by key benchmarks and challenges around
2012
gary's key claim centers around critical
capabilities which is to say symbolic
manipulation which he sees as
fundamentally missing from deep learning
today which is to say he thinks we're
building taller towers with the aim of
getting closer to the moon and of course
this depends on your definition of a
tower and indeed the moon in this
respect
there are active and vibrant lines of
research pursuing the unification of the
symbolic and the connectionist
approaches for example look at the
neurosymbolic cognitive approach of
professor louis lamb who we interviewed
on the show recently now when i was
reading around the various twitter
threads the thing that really jumped out
at me was the apparent lack of any
common understanding of what symbolic
meant i mean the most naive conceptions
of what it means to be symbolic are that
there are variables or discrete
structures in your system pedro domingos
made this very interesting post on
twitter quote xgboost is a symbolic
learner and works better than deep
learning for most problems i originally
thought he was making the somewhat naive
statement that xgboost had discrete
variables in it
so did neural networks i thought
but after discussing it with keith it
quickly became apparent that he meant
the holistic manipulation of learners as
symbols or nodes in the trees inside the
algorithm rather than the mere discrete
representation
gary said in his article that simply
having symbols and processing them
algebraically are two different things
it's the processing part which allows us
to robustly deal with abstractions in
novel situations
now let's have a look at gary's recent
next decade article symbolic operations
over variables offer one potential
answer a solution that is used trillions
and trillions of times every second of
every day
underlying virtually all of the world's
software in particular
four basic ideas undergird virtually
every compute program variables
instances
bindings that tie variables to instances
and operations over variables each of
these ideas is familiar from grade
school algebra in which entities like x
and y are variables specific numbers 2
3.5 etcetera are instances and those
variables might be bound for example x
might currently equal 3.
operations include things like addition
and multiplication
these make it possible to represent
relationships such as y equals x plus 2
that automatically extend to all values
in some class for example all numbers
the process of connecting a variable to
an instance is sometimes referred to as
variable binding
so what is he actually saying here well
first of all that we can defer attaching
values to variables or symbols the
implication here of course is that all
of the variables can be manipulated
abstractly algebraically building and
rearranging formulas regardless of any
particular value assignment or binding
now he makes a big deal out of saying
that all of the values inside some class
can be represented which is the
extrapolation out of the training range
point that he makes so frequently
i think the most important thing which
gary wanted to convey which he didn't
write down explicitly well i mean i
think he did later on actually but
it's this notion of abstract symbolic
manipulation rather than the mere
representation
let's look at the summary section of
gary's next decade article which he
released recently he said that symbolic
manipulation particularly the machinery
of operations over variables offers a
natural though incomplete solution to
the challenge of extrapolating beyond a
training regime
an algorithm in terms of operations over
variables and it will inherently be
defined to extend to all instances of
some class
it also provides a clear basis for
representing structured representations
such as tree structures
so
the summary section of gary's article is
instructive it makes it clear that he
thinks extrapolating outside of the
training regime performing operations
over variables and having discrete
structured representations are the most
important features of a symbolic model
now people think that gary eschews deep
learning but this couldn't be further
from the truth
he thinks that deep learning holds the
key to being able to learn knowledge
rather than having to explicitly capture
it by hand
i'm quoting
hybrids could be a way of combining the
best of both worlds the capacity to
learn from large-scale data sets as
exemplified by deep learning with the
capacity to represent abstractions which
are syntactic and semantic currency of
all of the world's computer programming
languages
now when i spoke with keith earlier we
thought that there might be four
possible conceptions of what symbolic
models actually are
the first conception is that of a
capability right which is to say
extrapolating outside of the training
range this is possibly what gary marcus
seems to be placing the most weight on
when we've spoken with him
the most simple definition is this idea
of discrete versus continuous which is
to say that your model
isn't differentiable basically
and the third definition would be
variable bindings which is to say being
able to assign values to variables
uh the fourth definition which i'm now
tending towards is this notion of
symbolic manipulation or gary calls it
algebraic manipulation
and i think basically what this means is
reasoning in the abstract domain not on
the values themselves but on symbols
representing their values
now humans are quite interesting right
because we perform symbolic manipulation
but we perceive this as happening on the
values instead of the symbols
now melanie mitchell put a very
interesting tweet out the other day she
linked a paper from 1982 it was from
alan newell talking about the
intellectual issues in the history of
artificial intelligence
newell focused on some important splits
which arose in the first 30 years of
research on artificial intelligence
things like symbols versus numbers and
continuous systems by the way continuous
systems pattern recognition
learning neural networks etc these were
all the domains of other fields right
for example cybernetics not artificial
intelligence
melanie was fascinated how the term
artificial intelligence now mostly means
this latter set of terms it's gone
completely 180 degrees
melanie spoke about our notions of what
intelligence actually is keeps changing
over time
are symbols necessary for intelligence
do symbols in artificial intelligence
need to emerge from non-symbolic
substrates in order to be grounded and
in order to avoid brittleness
is it more useful to focus on symbolic
behavior like andrew lampin and from
deepmind outlines in his latest paper
symbolic behavior and artificial
intelligence where he and his co-authors
argued that symbol use will emerge when
learning agents immerse in human social
cultural interactions demanding
coordination around perspectives and
meaning
lampanen invokes wittgenstein which is
to say that we ought to understand
language by examining how words are used
he also thinks that symbolic meaning can
and should be invented and continuously
adapted so instead of thinking about
whether a system engages with symbols we
should focus instead on characterizing
how it engages with symbols this is in
stark contrast to our friend waleed
sabha who's a big believer that we
discover all of these things we don't um
invent them we had a fascinating
discussion with professor j mark bishop
about this as well of course he's also
an ultra relativist and fan of
wickenstein
now um andrew is coming on the podcast
in a few weeks time so we'll do a deep
dive with him then
now the deep learning godfather
professor yan lacoon responded to
professor melanie mitchell he said that
he never called what he was working on
artificial intelligence ai was supposed
to designate symbolic methods
then around 2013 the public and the
media became interested in deep learning
and they called it artificial
intelligence but he couldn't explain why
artificial intelligence people didn't
view deep learning as ai all along he
said it made no sense to him which is
very very interesting
anyway now i give you leticia pacquiao
besco enjoy
although um
duggar why are you
you're still using your webcam
yes
i just got him to buy a dslr last year
and he's only used it as far as i can
tell once good luck installing that
it's uh no it you just plug it in it's
usbc he just hasn't plugged it in what
no no man it's it's right there it's
just i gotta arrange my desk differently
because right now my screen is here it's
just a space thing
space this is spacing
duggar quality
it's all about the production quality i
don't want to be in high res like that
who wants to look at me in high
resolution in fact i was going to put a
butter filter on me
okay all right i don't know i really
like the visual aspect of your podcast
really and i'm so happy you decided to
release the youtube stuff again but you
released so much lately that i cannot
catch up so that's also fact you'll have
you'll have time to catch up we're gonna
have a little lull for a bit i think
yeah i think we've gone a little bit
crazy i mean today this is the third one
we've done
wow
do you not have anything else to do like
uh i i do
i do and i've been trying to convince
tim of that to like kind of not burn us
out but um he wanted to conduct a quote
experiment so hopefully
i don't know how this came about i mean
we we said that we'd do some unplugged
conversations
and because we weren't going to prepare
for them we could just rinse it so we
just blocked out some time in our
calendar and we just thought you know
set up a calendar away we go and then
the calendar filled up very quickly and
then we suddenly realized that it's
against our religion not to prepare
so we just suddenly had about six times
more work to do than we did before but
it's good it's i really love it it's
stimulating
i think the
acceptance rate and the rate at which
the calendar filled up because initially
we didn't have it to where only one
person per day could sign up and i think
we just weren't expecting so many people
to
grab time on the calendar and then like
tim said
how
we can't not prepare at least to some
degree and so um
got ourselves in a painted in a bit of a
corner for a little while
it is yeah but i think it will pass
i i just it's a good time to be alive i
just can't believe you can set up a
youtube channel
and uh i mean
we've just got some amazing people
booked i just i can't believe it and i
mean you already had the i mean two of
the three biggest guys and i was
thinking like where would you go now
like yeah well you'll find out i mean
there's not much room to improve
it's it's incredible
so anyway enough about us leticia um why
don't you introduce yourself properly
oh hi
i'm leticia i am a phd student in my
third year at heidelberg university at
the department of computational
linguistics but do not get fooled by
computational linguistics because i do
both
vision and language so and
like to integrate these two modalities
images with text
and yeah that was what i do during my
daytime because now at night like you
can see i hang out on youtube
i have a youtube channel it's called the
ai coffee break and a coffee break that
was my romanian accent just pulling
through and yeah i have there a certain
miss coffee bean who now sleeps in that
coffee roaster over there and she helps
me explain latest machine learning
papers or concepts on youtube and i
think
it's a lot of fun
yeah i really recommend folks you you go
and subscribe to leticia's youtube
channel and um the the quality of your
content has come along so far as well
i'm really envious of how you produce
your videos and how you do the
animations and the amount of preparation
that you must put into the videos is
just unreal
and and you said
you're into computational linguistics
i'm surprised that yannick ever spoke
with you because he says to us that he
doesn't like talking with linguists
because they are too
uh they they bring up symbols too
quickly in the conversation
uh yeah that's not me i don't have
actually any linguistics training i
was you know i studied physics and
during my physics studies i like to
explore a lot and i explored computer
science too
and uh yeah if i had perhaps maybe if
i'd known about programming and computer
science during school already i would
have done that i'm not sure but i i
don't regret having studied physics at
all i did my masters in physics too
but also in parallel i studied computer
science and for my bachelor's thesis and
for my master's thesis i actually did
machine learning and for for my phd i
wanted to do so i found a professor who
wanted to do both text and vision with
me so and that was a professor at the
department of computational linguistics
and all the linguistics i know i i mean
what do i even know i learned from her
and i learned it just by doing it
i don't count myself as a linguist i
even sometimes ask myself where
am i at home because i feel comfortable
in many places but where is my home yeah
but i don't think i have to decide you
know i think you and i have a lot in
common there because um
when i was going away to college you
know a long long time ago uh
i had a hard time deciding what i wanted
to study because i liked everything you
know i liked engineering i liked math i
liked science chemistry all of it right
i enjoyed all of it so here's what i did
i just i looked through the catalog of
the highest paid starting salaries for
someone with a bachelor's degree
and at that time again a long time ago
let's say
early 90s
the top two were
electrical engineering and chemical
engineering
chemical engineering i think was second
and i i liked chemicals a lot you know i
fooled around with them a lot as a kid
so i chose that right and then
subsequently i started taking
programming courses
in college and and over the years you
know i shifted and gravitated more and
more towards
applied math and in particular
computational computational techniques
and so sometimes i have this same
thought like do i regret you know not
having just jumped straight into
computer science from the beginning but
i have to say
i really do enjoy the fact that i
learned so much about the actual
universe and you know
chemistry and physics and engineering
and i think at my core i really think of
myself as an is an engineer i just i
love solving problems and i love
learning because that helps me solve
problems um so i don't regret it but i
do wonder what would have happened if if
i had just gone straight into computer
science you know
yeah i can relate to that because i
studied physics in heidelberg because i
was looking at what the program has to
offer and i saw i could do also some
philosophy courses
and i didn't want to study a program
which was like you have to do that and
that and that but there's something with
more freedom and i
had the philosophy course i was so
disappointed by it that i said never
again and then i went into exploring
other things like mass and computer
science
yeah but regarding computational
linguistics i sometimes at the
department i am a little bit the
outsider the person that doesn't know
linguistics i think that's the reason
why anik talked to me
so
and i sometimes feel i i feel like i'm a
little bit
let's say not criticized but looked upon
like ah she she didn't uh use the right
term for that thing that she tried to
circumscribe because she didn't have the
proper training um
and but sometimes i feel like actually
it's really good to bring what i'm
bringing into
into the department like my knowledge
about physics and math it's actually
super useful because that helps me with
what is computational linguistics today
which is neural networks and
i mean computational linguistics was
about linguistics 20 30 years ago but
now the field has shifted and i think
the linguists like you know
had a fear that shifted from under their
feet and
went more into my direction where i'm
comfortable with neural networks and the
papers contain so much math that usually
linguists have so or my colleagues have
problems understanding them and um yeah
it's like a symbiosis it's uh i
explained the monthly parts and they
explained to me the high level and why
does this make sense linguistically
parts and then together we have
understood the paper and i think that's
great yeah it's interesting we spoke
with guy emerson a few weeks ago and
he's a linguist and um you know they're
interested in um things like um phrase
structure grammars and and it's it seems
quite alien to the average deep learning
person who's interested in
you know their much more statistically
uh inspired conception of language but
we were actually having this debate
yesterday keith weren't we about uh
where
computational linguistics came from and
apparently it was emitted in the 1950s
not by any particular person but it was
you know in in the early symbolic days
of ai it was about
you know making other basic efforts
towards things like translation and as
you say now linguistics isn't really
associated with the symbolic notion of
of ai there was a great thread by
melanie mitchell last night where
apparently um
you know these days we have this notion
of of deep learning and pattern
recognition and a lot of the symbolic
folks say that that's got nothing to do
with ai so i just wondered what's your
perception of teacher and do do you
think that modern
computational linguistics is ai
well
that's a question because i've i've been
following your podcast and you always
have this debate about symbolic and
i you know just
uh connectionist approaches and and we
want to drag you right into that that
debate leticia yeah exactly but i don't
know if i have an opinion or like a
stance or if i have one hill on which
i'm willing to die on i think that ball
both hills have a point and i feel this
uh two different hills with my professor
who's a linguist all the time because i
actually
like deep learning models and i like to
see them succeed but i also like to see
them fail and i think so one of my most
recent papers is about
setting them up to fail in the sense
with this vision and language models on
whether they have understood things
understood yeah things like
are they able to count stuff in an image
and are they able to to see what's a
correference or are they able to
distinguish actions or who's the acting
like if if i change a sentence from the
baby shall the woman shouts at the baby
or the baby shouts at the woman if that
if that you know is noticed or not given
that there is a picture depicting that
certain action
yeah and so it's uh i love to see neural
networks fail
too um
and uh you know there's this this
question of whether
is it
that more data and bigger models can get
you to
ai and i don't think it couldn't take
you i really think that's a shot we
should take i mean that's one way to go
uh to take up the ai flag and and plant
it onto that hill because
we have seen that i mean you can you
could start from a blank slate that's
again a notion that tim says all the
time like blank slate and throw
data and throw
um model capacity i did and with a lot
of a lot of training time and instances
you could figure out that um signal that
is in the data the problem is sometimes
that the signal is so less often
represented in the data that you that
you think it's noise or the neural
network thinks it's noise and actually
it's interesting signal and
to to push it further to to grab that
signal which it thinks it no it's noise
you could try with inductive biases and
so on and push it a little further but
but it's like could you could you just
throw so much infinitely many
things off
in amount of capacity and yes you could
eventually
maybe uh get to mimic what evolution has
done
i think that's one way to do it the
other way to do it is to take the things
that we already know and to take the
theories
that we already know to
i mean we already have figured out that
there's some structure in in this world
and and take that and inject it as is
and try to operate on that and try to
to also
so we
we have no problems writing down a
symbolic program to compute something
and maybe let's
teach ai to to do that too but it's it's
like two different paradigms and i don't
know which one is the winning card so
let's play both and i don't think
there's a reason to argue i mean of
course it's interesting intellectually
and it makes for great twitter threads
and twitter files that i like to follow
to see like what's best and people
always go with the ticket they have
already written a grant about but
you know i i am accepting of both and i
i
find both sides fascinating and both
people representing them fascinating
yeah and i think
you know let's say the the reason or the
value and arguing about them is um
more about how society allocates its its
resources and there is this phenomenon
of the pendulum that swings right i mean
and
we've talked to
the people who lived through this where
back in the day the folks the
connectionists were you know shunned and
told to go sit in the corner and you
know we're told that they were working
on nonsense and and then of course uh
there became enough computational power
and stagnation and symbolics that that
they uh started to be successful and
then the pendulum swings the other way
where it's like no everything is and i
think that's in human nature to kind of
swing one way or the other and that's
kind of a problem like that's not really
the optimal way to proceed you know we
have to keep kind of as you're
advocating for
all avenues open we need people to be
kind of in this engaged in this
open-ended search as tim would you know
kind of call it um to look around for
stepping stones to have more serendipity
and i think some of us perceive that
when
there's too much dogmatism and when
things have gone too extreme in one
direction or the other you have to push
back against it to try and get at least
a few people out there a few more people
let me say out there to open up their
minds a bit and explore some
uh less well-explored areas
yeah but i think that's less of a
scientific question like are we going
now that way or that way it's more of a
societal question because scientists
form a society too and they have the
same power dynamics and the same
the rich get richer um kinds of
situations and yes it's uh it's exactly
it's not a question how can we get
that voice that advocates for i know
some research direction but how can we
get to highlight any voice and this is
also related to a review being uh into
the reviewing system that is also
one mechanism that pushes down on
some of the interesting avenues and
pushes this
janik calls them the papers you cannot
you cannot reject and i've encountered
them as a reviewer because it's a paper
that is like yup
well i mean it had all the points
right and it's not too
novel but not too uh you know copying
something it's just you you cannot
reject it and you accept it and it's
like it's this loop you cannot get out
from and then people who have already
some voice and they will have followers
and voice and it's hard to to get
you know
attention to to some other directions
okay but and that's i think
what you know this
channel
does sometimes and can do a lot yeah but
taking that into account it seems that
for your own personal research you've
chosen a little bit of the path
less taken right to try and marry up
these two very different paradigms and
i'm curious i'm curious i think it's not
taken
but from where i am sitting it looks
like a very well taken path and i mean
it wasn't taken when i started it but
and i've been at it for three years now
but now multimodality and vision and
language especially it becomes very
became very sexy and people try to do it
and there has been these huge models now
from google from facebook and and
at the beginning i didn't have a model
to work with like i was still thinking
about it producing this model that would
solve everything right but then there
was the first huge model from my i don't
know which wilbert and that was people
also related to facebook i think um and
and then there was another one and it's
another one and then now there's like 24
such models and i'm like
how to compare them even because you
know for you strive for novelty because
you want to write this paper that nobody
can reject and uh you take this thing
which is basically done already and then
you put another uh head another data set
another training task so you kind of
switch it up a little
you are not comparable anymore because
if you change the data how should you
even compare and you have these 24
eclectic things that uh everybody is
interested in and everybody tries to
push their own thing out and i think so
where i stand from yes it's it's not
perhaps not so talked about it as other
topics maybe what i really meant but
still yeah what i really meant and what
i wanted to ask you about was
when you decided to take that path it
was the path less taken now nowadays
there's more interest in it but what
drove you personally to
to be so interested in multi-modality
and you know data fusion and fusion
fusing the paradigms i think i had
experience in computer vision
it's not really that
that was my absolute and ultimate
passion and i thought that text would be
this absolutely i mean more on the
linguistic side i i wanted to to work
with um texts that i always loved i i
loved to read during my during high
school times especially when i had a lot
of time to do that
and uh
and to marry those things was like let's
bring some knowledge i already have and
try to get something new to it too which
was a text troll part
yeah it's uh
it's not
more
well thought than that i think sometimes
i mean you you say yeah there's a bigger
picture like artist that's an
unresearched first path i want to go to
into that it's uh
it's more like
a greedy optimization procedure i had
applied there it was
luck too that i found somebody who does
that and and all of that to fit
to
the environment i wanted to stay in
which was heidelberg and
that's how it happened and i think
it's most important what you do out of
it and uh less like
how it happens soon come along i i'm
quite interested in multi modality it
was it was actually speaking with jeff
hawkins that sold me on the idea so you
know he's got this notion that we have
all of these sensory motor circuits in
our brain and they were connected to
different parts of our body so when we
pick up an almond we can
actually detect the complete object just
by touch
and
in that notion
because we have so many different
diverse signals we can recognize objects
very robustly
especially in lots of partial
information domains because the thing
i'm you know i'm always trying to square
the circle of why does deep learning
work at all and as you were just saying
before it's you know what does it mean
to understand right i don't know whether
you were talking about a visual question
answering model or some kind of scene
recognition model but you know the baby
shouts at the woman
um and the problem is that there's a lot
of missing information and we need to
reason to fill in the gaps and deep
learning doesn't do that but maybe multi
modality is a way of overcoming that
problem
yeah and this is exactly the pitch you
could use for grants because and that's
what you write in your introductions
about multimodality and that's perfect
but then and that's what i hoped to
achieve when i started but then what i
actually saw is the unrobustness of deep
learning models because you have
so let's stay simple we have two
modalities it could be more i mean
it ideally it should be as many as
possible because then you are super
robust right um but you have vision and
language and and there are
there are tasks you want to solve like
visual question answering and the
you have the question yeah so how many
dogs are there in the image
and then the model has to count
but then you don't notice this as a
programmer you have uh or as a data set
collector you have a bias in your data
set and when you ask how many then it's
still because if you ask how many it's
usually already more than one it's uh
two because it could be three two but
the probability is less but it's not
four usually it's not five or six
because
especially these data sets were conduct
constructed such that models could
handle them and if you count
many object objects you have the problem
of occlusion and and things are starting
to merge with each other so usually you
stay that load numerals and therefore
this model that is multimodal looks at
both vision and language actually just
looks at the tokens at the end grams
like how many
and then answers too
and so you would expect that uh these
this additional information brings in
more information but it doesn't but but
let's suppose this is a simple task and
a simple task and and it's it's obvious
and there's data set biases but then you
have the problem of um so let's suppose
you you want to do emotion
classification and you have text and in
text you sometimes do not understand
irony or sarcasm because
you don't know the person and you don't
know that if they use that word
combination it's a sarcasm so it would
be awesome if you would have the speech
modality too so the auditorium
the audio signal to have this voice that
will tell you immediately looked at it's
sarcasm
but the problem there is again you have
combined um
in a sense not so varied modality which
is text
with a very varied modality which is
speech because in speech you can have
um i mean different voices and then you
have different personalities and
everybody expresses their sarcasm in a
different way and
in in text it's it's just tokens and yes
for every token it could be a 30 000
possibilities or how large the english
vocabulary is like 50k
big but also the probability to assign
as to uh to have some tokens next to
each other is is kind of zero so you
don't say
he is tired he say you say he um well
you say he is tired and i wanted to make
a dangerous girl he he are tired you
don't say that you say he is tired so he
and r is a combination an engram that is
absolutely unlikely so from this 30 000
possibilities we have actually reduced a
lot of them but and that's on the
textual side which has
less possibilities but on the on the
sig audio signal side you have actually
a lot of possibilities and
again so
neural networks or deep learning scales
as long as the signal or the the data is
in such an amount that the the things
you want to discover that are there as a
signal but if the
the variance in the
auditory modality is so high that the
model things all the time it's noise it
will just ignore the modality and you
pretend you have a multi-modal model and
look it takes both inputs and does
things with them and you see even
attention maps
between them but actually
you know it's not doing as much because
it's um the loss function is more easily
minimized if you just look at one
modality and you have this unimodal
collapse you you think you're
multi-modal but you're not and it's
actually super hard to to integrate
modalities because they have the
representations of different variants
and different
dimensionality and i think that you had
yeah you had done bacon on your podcast
and he was saying about how he dreams
about going to video and i'm like wow we
uh we didn't have we didn't solve the
image
thing uh already but let's uh yeah let's
go into video and let's make their mark
but we will have we will spend years of
making video i'm integrating video with
some text robust to i mean to really
make them on the same level and not just
think we solved it multimodally but
actually yeah solve it
because because you're talking a lot
there about some of the stuff that
waleed sabha talks about which is i mean
he doesn't believe it's possible to to
do statistical learning because you know
um you need to have logical uh type
constraints uh rather than just looking
at co-occurrences and i think some of
the stuff you were talking about is the
problem with the shortcut rule in deep
learning as well but um i wanted to
touch on a few things there because
we've been speaking about noam chomsky
and uh chomsky introduced three things
to linguistics i'm told firstly that
language has biological underpinnings a
bit like the visual system he thinks
that there's a kind of language module
in the brain um hawkins completely
disagrees of course and um he vehemently
railed against this statistical
learnability of language uh with his
famous poverty of stimulus argument and
this is why i wanted to loop it into
this part of the conversation because um
walid sabra also argued that there's
just this infinite set of language
right and he he just completely
disagrees that it could be learned
empirically at all
um
yeah what do you think
but that's exactly the arguments i'd use
uh to say that it's actually only
statistically uh capturable because what
i
that's what i argue with my students
because they're linked with
computational linguists and i i was
asking them
how else to do it if not statistically
because if um and i perhaps there are
persons who know better but that's just
my opinion that uh
okay
um
i i would expect so um a theory so i
would expect from linguistics the theory
that explains
one language completely and and
possibly not um
not um
artificial language but the language
that people use and people use during
when they talk
and i don't think that's possible
because language is extremely uh
changing and uh i mean
language we think that it is what we
learn at school there's these rules and
so on yes but this is just a snapshot of
the moment we are learning it but then
in the next year there is uh
i call it the language police so i don't
know if that's the case in every for
every language or in every in every
country but in romania there is a called
academia so there's a
language police so there's a there's a
set of people deciding when to update
grammar rules and when to update
pronunciation rules and and writing
rules and so on and when they decide
let's update then the dictionaries get
updated and then the standard of the
language gets updated
but that and that's an update that
happens
every few years but uh
that's one update that happens but then
there's the update that happens all the
time if i start to use with my friend
always the word
uh pizza for saying coffee then pizza
will be
a replacement for coffee and if we
understand each other when we're doing
that that will be it and then if the
community enlarges and this happens
which uses words in a certain way
it doesn't even matter what rules where
and uh what what the
theory says as long as we understand
each other some things will be picked on
and and used like that and uh if i see a
theory that is so
um
um you know it's so elastic that it can
capture all of these things and and
change as fast as the language itself
then i would say yes there are rules
there are symbols there are things we
can model
one language or all languages with and
we can use theories or
symbolic or only symbolic
representations to to
you know solve the problem
but because i think that it's all about
statistics that you have to update all
the time so you have to have a
continuously trained model on
on language because if you train gpt3
today it's already yesterday it's
you capture i mean it doesn't follow
every
new signal
and yeah i think statistically by
continuously up updating your statistics
you can capture such a heterogeneous and
eclectic mess which i think it's
language and i have i think i have um
upset every
linguist
but that's my opinion i don't know that
you've upset them but if but if i put my
uh
linguist you know devil's advocate hat
on not that i'm a linguist but um
if i put that hat on i think the
objection is
all the things that you just brought up
you know let's say they're true
but they're actually a distraction
really from the core issue here because
even if i just made you know i waved a
magic wand and caused everyone in the
world to speak you know a single
unified natural language that never
changes okay
i would still have the problem that
and even if it was context-free you know
suppose i just give you a context-free
grammar right those simple production
rules can generate this vast
combinatorial space of you know possible
sentences and if you try to go backwards
like you try to go backwards from
lots of examples of sentences to
rediscover what that underlying
context-free grammar is
the problem from a statistical point of
view is
you would have to have a massive
coverage
space in order to
reverse engineer those rules so that's
the fundamental kind of
problem here it's not so much about
infinities it's just more that in order
to cover the space sufficiently to infer
those rules you know to go from the
extension of the language to the
intention
of the language that's the problem not
all this changing you know whatever else
and i accept that in a sense you brought
up the curse of dimensionality up and i
think that is a problem but we have seen
deep learning all the time trying to
tackle it and in more and more
successful ways and i think
maybe it's not it's not that impossible
and i don't say that statistical methods
would solve the problem it would again
need updates and again learning and
again more data to capture things that
were not initially in distribution i
always say that i mean there's this
generalization question and the question
of going out of distribution i don't
believe in it i think that
everything the model can do is what's in
distribution what it's out this
distribution and it can do it can do by
chance because sometimes decision
boundaries just happen to fit
but if we i mean why larger and larger
training data and larger models help is
that everything that you think is out of
distribution is actually in distribution
especially combined with
us humans that i mean who knows what the
pile is the the data that the pile has
all in it we don't know and then we test
it with an example and are impressed
like how that that works
and that's out of distribution that was
not seen as well during training i think
that that was a little more in
distribution than we
we humans think uh but now getting back
to
to the question of uh linguistics of
capturing that language that you have
just made with your magic wand super
nice and and you said the problem would
be just a combinatorial
complexity
then i agreed to with you that then in
that case um
just going all symbolic that might
actually do the trick but i don't
believe i think that the magic wand
there is absolutely
far from reality just because
language is something very
human
and the thing is that it will change
and it will have strange things in it
i think it's more regular than people
give it credit for i mean otherwise deep
learning wouldn't work at all it might
be a little bit like you know on a
fractal pattern like if you look at the
mandelbrot set there are areas of
regularity because you could say as
walid does that language is this
countably infinite set
but actually if you look at colloquial
language which is used by most of us it
it's not it probably is is much more
manageable maybe somewhat amenable to
memorization but to what you were saying
um a few minutes ago about just the
complexity of a nuance of language
chomsky doesn't only say that language
has a biological underpinnings you know
he says that um the innateness and
universality of language across cultures
and and different parts of of the world
it's something which is completely built
into us and that flies in the face of
this notion of language being an epi
phenomenon or being an emergent
phenomenon but i wondered whether you
thought both could be true because you
know when we
think sometimes we perform reasoning and
calculations in our head and sometimes
we memorize things and it might be
possible for both of those things to be
true at the same time and i wanted to
make one other comment as well so and
you said about the the flux of language
and we're seeing that now on social
media so in russia right now um going
for a walk means going for a protest
and on on instagram spicy means sexy
content
so
it's just incredibly how quickly
language can evolve
exactly and as i said i think in the
beginning it's it's good to have both of
these hills so now i would i i'm just i
just defended the opinion with which i
would go if i would want to
progress something in the next few years
because i don't actually see progress
from symbolism i i honestly it's just
perhaps it's a media coverage or it's
just that
it seems like statistics is the way to
go for now until we have something
better but i believe that we should
really also look into other directions
and see what what could maybe work
better but yes it could be a combination
of both things and that's what people
usually also say so there's these people
who say we should we need a
nah a morph
between the two paradigms because some
things you can capture with rules but to
have a meta thing that that works on on
all of this it's
it's the way to go but for me it's uh
it's uh you know it's
nice to think about this these these
things and to talk about these things
it's just um
disappointing how
much you can actually do from the phd
perspective i think that's a great
supervisor talk like to to have a batch
of phd students work on these things but
then when you ask yourselves like how
can i introduce memory into my neural
network
i'd like to push back on on something
which is um
you said you don't see much progress
from symbolist i think the correct way
to say that is you don't see much
progress in symbolism teaching machines
how to do
symbols right or symbolics because
the fact is human beings are symbolic
and so every single paper that's written
every single neural network that's
designed every mathematics formula
that's created every piece of software
that's written is all symbolics like
it's all written in symbolics that is
the progress
of symbolics like the fact is when we
look around all human progress almost
all human progress is largely driven by
symbolic thought and symbolic reasoning
which is why you know we so desperately
want to teach machines
how to do symbolic reasoning so i think
it's correct to say that we've had a lot
of trouble teaching machines how to do
symbolic reasoning i think it's totally
inco correct to say there's no progress
by symbolism like virtually the world
runs on symbolics
you're right yeah but i'm always that's
a question i am actually encountering
especially when i'm thinking about multi
modalities what is the language or the
way the proper way of thinking for
machines and are we actually
demanding the right thing from machines
to think like us and again it's a not a
no that i can decide on the hill i want
to die on i just think i'm
it's a little unfair to
to request from machines to do
everything as we do yes i think machines
are
here i mean we program them because we
want to them to improve our life quality
in some sense
but and so the output should be
understandable by us the output should
help us so it should be us driven right
but the internal mechanisms of how that
machine achieves this desirable output
for us
it's i mean it could be
either way and and uh when i was asking
myself what is even what multi modality
is i
came across a lot of
uh human centered definitions that were
like i mean we see we hear we taste we
touch so
machines should do the same but
it's like even when i'm considering just
seeing from and i'm expecting seeing
from machines uh seeing is all about
capturing photons with a detector and
here we have a detector machines could
have a better detector that don't
capture only well a certain range of
photon energy but
more like
every range of photon energy and that
would be a machine
that sees but again how can we or should
we expect a human-like
processing of x-ray plus infrared plus
microwave plus radio and this on um data
should we or should we not and i am not
decided i'm just
saying that let's not have the throw in
the
human
measurement and apply it on machines
because sometimes we could limit their
their super humanness and i'm not saying
that they will talk over the world but
it's just that they will do things that
we cannot do no i i think you're for us
uh there are people who make that
argument okay and and for example
we recently spoke to uh pey wang and he
um you know he's got a nice formalism
that that draws these distinction
between
what type of similarity to human you
know thought are you looking for are you
looking for similarity of behavior
similarity of structure similarity of
capability function etcetera but i think
where i'm coming from more is from a
practical practical kind of point of
view which is
if i'm trying to
create machine intelligence or machine
general intelligence for example
if we if we all agree that human beings
are
generally intelligent you know i was
posit that that's the case
it's the only extant example of a system
that is generally intelligent and so we
try to take
you know inspiration from it and in the
case of even neural networks they were
directly inspired by the lowest level
sort of
uh functional structure inside the brain
which is neurons um but it throws away
so much other inspiration that we can
gain from from the structure of the
brain if you're starting at that low end
and then of course we all know
or we all have firsthand experience with
how we think how we simulate the world
in our minds how we game situations how
we think about
objects and and the world around us and
so i i think all i'm saying is that
it's very useful or could be very useful
to draw
to continue to draw inspiration and not
just stop with with an abstracted neuron
like that's not the end of the
inspiration absolutely
yeah so i i mean my if i would have
infinite money and to do research like
infinite money like what would i put
people on i think i would invest in
biology or in uh neuroscience to to just
interesting understand us because if i
think we could be understood like uh the
late the last mechanism that uh that
builds us that would be something really
cool because then we could just uh
re-implement it right again somehow and
that would be
the next infinite amount of money i
would invest to start to recreate what
we know all about us but because we are
not yet there i'm not at all there to
understand what's going on in here and i
don't think here is everything it's like
this thing that so like everything we
have to understand
uh we we're not there so i think perhaps
this is so complex that we until we
understand this thing to maybe
re-implement it we should keep all our
options open and and go with
abstractions and because abstractions
have helped us a lot i mean in
physics is in a sense a way of
approximating every horse by a circle
and it works really well sometimes
i mean it depends how how far you want
to get but
to build a really useful products for
people to to use ai products i think
statistics is fine it's uh and we should
explore how to do that
well and and to build agi maybe we
should keep our
options open and i mean so much of this
comes down to whether you think
intelligence is a pilot trick you know
like we we
we love taking the piss out of gpt3
don't we but you know we say that it's a
parlor trick of intelligence and you
know the statistical approach is
basically interpolating statistically
between things and that works really
well if you're inside the distribution
of things
but it doesn't work very well when
you're outside of the distribution of
things
and and then maybe human intelligence is
a similar parlor trick right i mean we
were talking with a guy earlier
about cellular automata
and it's just remarkably you know like
the game of life conway's game of life
just with some simple rules you can
create this emergent life-like behavior
and that's just incredible and you know
it's entirely possible that human
behavior is is just a similar part of
trick in in a sense
and that's the reason i would invest
that infinite money into biology and
understanding ourselves because i want
to understand if if this is just a power
what is it all about and all these
expectations about ai would be even more
realistic because we would see what this
uh
example of x uh like super good example
of um intelligence is all about because
we argue all the time is this
intelligent is this not intelligent and
we move the goal post about intelligence
all the time so yeah that that's why i i
would be
it's not something that like i would uh
that's interesting it's not something
that i would like to do research in
because i feel it's um
yeah it's not something i would act like
personally do research in but i would
give that infinite money to to
understand this parlor trick or if maybe
it isn't because then we would know
right we would have one we investigated
one way of creating intelligence we
could think about maybe if there's other
intelligences because we would know what
this intelligence is all about
fascinating well um letitia how do you
could i mean you've got an incredibly
mature process now for creating content
for doing research for structuring
things i'm just really interested to
know what that process looks like and
how has it kind of matured over time
yeah it has matured over time every time
i look at
one of my first videos i have to cringe
but you know it's it still gets some
clicks so i don't understand didn't we
delete our first videos no i'm only
kidding we're still there
yours were good from the very beginning
that's that's great on the other on the
other channel but you also have upped
your game i know yeah it's uh so people
ask me this like how do i do the videos
and um i wish it i'm a perfectionist and
what i've learned through the youtube
channel is actually to leave this
perfectionism a little bit aside because
if i
am perfectionist until the end i will
never release everything because i
always have to
leave the perfectionism behind tim did
you hear that
yeah the curse of perfectionism is is a
real problem
yeah exactly because you end up doing
spending too much time to optimize for
that latest 20 of quality which is i
believe in overfitting of content you
can overfit content it you think it's
good and tim think it thinks it's good
but keith then thinks it's ah crap he
should we should have invested more time
on that and that it's like uh and to to
cover a broad audience you i don't think
you need that last 20 80 is just fine
and i had to learn that because
otherwise i wouldn't have released my
first video and then now it's cringe so
that's the the
the outcome out of it but i i always
think i should improve for the next
video if i did something wrong right now
it's okay next video and um yeah what i
do is i actually read the paper and then
try to explain it in a
script i write a script uh i could talk
you know
freely like for example yannick doesn't
i think that should be is this a very
good
way of learning uh like how to present
something and so on but i i am a
perfectionist i cannot leave that script
b and i write it and i i you know i try
to write it like it's written in a
spoken language it's not the sound
formal
and then i go on to powerpoint and
people are like what you're using
powerpoint for animating but yes the
thing is that uh you know this morph
functionality uh to trans make a
transition between slides you have
something which is outside of you and
then you have the next slide where
something is inside of you and then you
click morph and then it does this and
you don't that's your keyframe here up
and here down
and
then i record it and cut it and
enter miss coffee bean during editing
and that was the whole parlor trick
that is fascinating i mean you've said
some really interesting things i mean
first of all i actually agree with you
that that con the content is king and
the script is king and what interests me
personally is is just how i present
information
and you're very very similar to me and i
know yannick is quite different in the
sense that it's all off the cuff
although i think it's off the cuff less
than you think i think the partner trick
of yannick is that there's more more
going on behind the scenes than you
realize but um but no the other thing
you said which was very interesting is
that um
there's there's there's an exploration
versus exploitation trade-off i noticed
this i've got a team of engineers
working for me at work and we always
have this thing that you know should we
do more analysis now or should we just
start coding
and every time we start coding we're
creating technical debt and actually the
only valuable commodity that we're
getting out of any work is information
and there's always this notion that you
know you could you could overfit on a
video or actually if you just put it out
there you'll gain valuable information
and then that information will make a
better video next time so it just feels
like this continuous cycle yeah
and that's so that's what i would say to
anybody who wants to start they say i'm
not good enough yes for the first video
and nobody will watch you and nobody
will watch you for two reasons first you
don't have any followers or subscribers
and youtube won't push you so even if
your vid first video is like the
greatest video of all time it will get
50 clicks not nothing from your family
and friends
but then if you start if you have
something out there
there
people i mean clicks can accumulate and
then for the second video it will stash
and then again and you will have this
curve of growing and growing
followers and if your first video is
crap your second video is good and your
first third video is even better then
you increase quality within the same
paces views are increasing and
this first video doesn't matter so much
and i think
so
the community is full of people who are
super smart i mean i see that in my
comments all the time they're so smart
and
have
i mean they could do it better than me
they just don't do it
and because i know they're afraid of
starting and they say don't they don't
have time but i think it's it's really
worth it and there's not much diversity
in terms of machine learning content or
youtubers you can watch and just come
and and do it yourself if you think if i
get these requests hey the teacher make
a video about that and that no do it
yourself you will read the paper you
will understand it and
i mean what is a better way of
understanding a paper than explaining it
to somebody else nothing so so just do
it yeah and this is so this has come up
quite often actually this this idea you
know this kind of agile loop right where
you're supposed to
observe decide act quickly and just keep
cycling around and it's even the
scientific method right we're supposed
to
observe hypothesize test and then keep
repeating that exactly you know a friend
of mine in school said um
if if it worked if research worked the
first time it would just be called
searching
right that's the idea we have to keep
repeating so the agile cycle and looping
i think is by far you know the most
effective
path forward for almost any any activity
i can push back a little bit on on that
though um
you know that there's still the curse of
empiricism and there's still the curse
of overfitting on the information that
you're getting back uh you know
keith and i had this discussion the
other day i think there was a veritasium
video about you know not overfitting
your youtube metrics and also when you
get a community i agree if you're a
teacher i mean we've just launched a
discord community and it is insane the
buzz the diversity the pointers there
are so many um just just bits of work
and people that i had no idea about and
we're being pointed in that direction
but by the same token we're also
overfitting and becoming typecast by i
mean if we ask our community now what
kind of content should we produce
they'll say oh just keep doing what
you're doing exactly do you know what i
mean so it's really it's a very
difficult problem and i don't say it's
easy it's just uh sometimes it's and
that's why because it's so hard and the
signals are sometimes not clear or even
pushing you into different directions
just do what you love that's i think the
most important thing because if let's
suppose my audience requests me a video
about the paper i would hate like why
would i do that just because i would get
a million clicks um
no i mean i i'm into it because i have
fun out of it and it i mean perhaps
that's my my reason i do it as a hobby i
don't do it as a as a job and as long as
it is a hobby i would i will do whatever
i like to do and not push myself to do
things just for clicks or for money
and i i think that most people who would
start to create machine learning content
would would relate to this because i
don't think that would be their
full-time job especially not from the
very first start
no
i was just gonna say i wasn't advocating
for overfitting i'm just saying that
quicker cycles quicker smaller cycles
are are better than than very long
detail planned indeed over fit you know
cycles the idea is to really go for that
that agility it's kind of the worst is
better model and what letitia said
earlier
worry about the 80
don't obsess about the 20 just release
repeat you know
yeah exactly
the way i like to articulate this is you
know life is fundamentally about a
missing information problem
we talk about it in our deep learning
models god if only we could fill in the
missing information but it's the same
thing in our life and we want to elicit
that missing information and the actions
that we take to elicit that information
we don't want it to cost too much
whether it's technical debt or doing
things that we don't want to do
but it's a bit more complicated than
that because we can um you know let's
say we've got a diverse sampling
strategy and we get a load of um we get
a load of information but those are the
small arrows and actually we also need
to elicit the big arrows and the big
arrows are an emergent property of the
system right so my engineers say to me
all the time where's the big arrow right
what are we doing and and actually the
more abstract and emergent the big arrow
is the harder it is to quantify it right
so i say oh we're building an
engineering culture well we're doing
this and we're doing that no i don't
believe you
you know quantify it for me
right yeah i think the bigger arrow is
something you want to capture when this
is a job and where you really i mean
where your money or outcome depends on
how well you have captured the
uncertainty of the problem and what i'm
actually advocating for especially when
it's it comes to creating content it's
uh yeah
it's like in life
where it's a lot about the missing
information and uncertainty just uh
relax and and i think it's a hard thing
for me to do like really hard because
i'm a perfectionist but i'm telling
myself just relax and do something see
the outcome rings and repeat because if
i am investing in
capturing that big vector i will have
spent so much time and so much
uncomfortable time this this time of
planning and then what should i do it's
not the time i have actually fun with
which is
drawing a new miss coffee bean stance
which is like yeah i want to do her with
hearts in her eyes today that's fun
and uh yeah it's
it's a hard balance exactly like in life
because you want to to get a good
outcome but you also want to enjoy
yourself i think that's for me the most
important thing because i otherwise i
would quit if it wouldn't be any fun so
yeah i think you're you're more grown up
you hurt him because you're like the
work and i want to feel the work
not not really i mean we're talking a
lot with kenneth stanley and i'm reading
a book called the tyranny of metrics at
the moment and a big part of that is
about embracing subjectivity and and
embracing diversity and and as you just
said you know like the your approach to
your channel it's very subjective and
it's very interesting to you
and um it would not be a good idea to
try and quantify or overquantify what
you're doing
you you just believe that it leads
somewhere interesting
it depends i mean i could go into a
local minimum as well i mean it could
happen it's just that
if it happens i think well okay bye
yeah but it would be
it would more likely happen because
that's the thing as soon as you you um
objectify something then you block
yourself from discovering the actual
thing you should be doing or even from
from an understanding point of view if
you delude yourself that you understand
what you're doing then that will block
you from the deeper understanding that
would have come later
yeah i mean
we're also all
as a as almost a civilization you know
we suffer from this um
this selection bias right because we
only see the things that survived and
that were
that were successful by and large we
don't see
all the 10x more
kind of failed attempts right and so we
get this false perception that
oh well hey obviously you can plan and
be successful because everything i look
at is successful
you know no it's just you only happen to
see the things that were that were
successful but a lot of it is really
serendipity and so
it's almost a futile attempt you know to
try and plan too much
for success and and tim this is kind of
where the
i don't know that it's so much deception
is it's more just inevitability that
that failure is kind of more likely than
than success and so
it's best just to pursue what you're
passionate about and then you have
enough energy to keep moving around and
moving forward until you do find success
exactly because on youtube where it's
all about you in front of a computer and
comments so not really people who
you know
give feedback like your family would do
or like
colleagues who do at work it's uh you
can become your worst
policeman or how should i say you could
ruin your fun yourself by taking the too
seriously by looking at the metric and
saying oh today i had 20 less
subscribers than yesterday what happened
and and you know try to interpret it too
much and
even i think even the worst comments on
youtube can hurt you less than you can
hurt yourself by
by taking it too seriously and not being
content with how it's going and looking
at others and saying ah they have
so many more subscribers than i do it's
yeah it's all and that's what youtube
teaches me to relax a bit i'm lucky in
one respect there which is the worst
comments i find more
you know i wouldn't say amusing but look
i'm open to any kind of criticism and so
when come somebody comes across you know
we get them they're just like angry and
and just
cursed
you know telling them
telling us to like almost drop dead and
things like that and i when i see those
i just think like whoa what's up what's
up with this person are you okay you
know i mean let's
let's i i wish i had the time but if i
did have the time i'd happy to talk
about this like i don't i don't want you
to think i'm your your mortal enemy out
there you know do you have your favorite
worst comment yeah i've got it right
here look we've hardly been i'm actually
joking about this and i'm smiling about
it because no because we we've not
really had any negativity just towards
us yeah yeah no i mean like you probably
count it on on one hand i think there
are only two cases where i've had to
block someone from commenting on the
channel and i mean this is it here i
probably shouldn't read it out loud but
can you please shut your blowhole from
what
you can't pronounce the same old [ __ ] i
shouldn't swear uh
stop it it's disgusting
uh
anyway you know yeah lots of lots of bad
ones
i blocked that person but other than
that it's it's all been overwhelmingly
positive actually
and yeah like that like you know if it
was possible i would i wouldn't i would
love to talk to them and just just
figure out look hey i'm open to
criticism like early on some guy was
really trashing me in you know one of
our early videos and i'm like
cool like tell me tell me more i don't
want to be annoying to you i don't want
to be you know some jerk on here like
let me know you know
it's not even your problem because it's
his problem he should just
not watch the video
i think that's the power is in their
hands
about the positivity i could say so to
encourage people even more to just do
videos about machine learning and so on
i had um you know not the perfect time
during my phd now during corona times
where you know i could have gone to
punta cana in the
dominican republic and it was online i
could have gone to seattle but it was
online i could have gone to this one and
it was online and it was so demotivating
to publish papers and to to get the
reviews from three random reviewers who
just
you know give their opinion and
if they even would have read the paper
that would have been great but they
didn't they just opinion they gave their
opinion there and really it was the
not motivating at all and if i uh if i
got some off and we were doing home
office so i didn't even have this a
constant call the uh so colleagues
constantly in my office to talk to them
and so on but i had youtube comments and
really they were so encouraging and and
it was a piece of good
mood and positivity even in this bad
times and when i was sick with papers
and i didn't want to see papers anymore
because
i
expected more from mine or something and
then but i saw
look it
it's great yeah
awesome well um letitia thank you so
much for coming on the channel it's been
an amazing conversation
thanks for inviting me especially
thank you for all you
and thank you for all your support
behind the scenes too you know it's it's
really appreciated
to have you i mean you really deserve it
and i wish i would have more time to
to support you much more than i actually
do yeah
well we would love you to be a
co-interviewer again so we'll um i mean
if folks have any suggestions actually
for a guest where we could have a
teacher as a co-interviewer um just let
us know in the comments yeah because um
that melanie mitchell show was amazing i
mean i'm so gutted actually that the the
audio quality wasn't good but other than
that it was it was an amazing show and
and leticia was a co-interviewer on that
yeah it was really
amazing like
wow i wouldn't have otherwise met
any person of that caliber
at this time
i don't melanie mitchell's book i i'd
honestly i think it's the best it's
probably the best book on ai that that
i've ever read um she is a huge
inspiration really good
yeah well [ __ ] she is so good
but um yeah i mean gary marcus's book is
really good as well but yeah i'm i'm a
huge fan of metadata
yeah but i mean um so charley's book is
about deep learning and i love deep
learning but i mean melody's book is
about ai in general
yeah but when i read francois schuli's
book it's like so what i was excited
about is that i especially book about
deep learning i
have i
admittedly i didn't read many books but
i think that's also reason that
uh i didn't i mean the flow of words and
the ideas in his book is incredible i
cannot stop reading it's like a novel
where something exciting happens like
what's going on because his flow of
ideas from one sentence to the next is
so clear and so you cannot you cannot
stop it's like wow yeah i know francois
is really gifted actually his his
writing acumen is just out of this watch
i think that's the reason why his um
twitter is is so popular because he just
has this incredible um
it's almost like an observational
ability so he just recognizes very
salient things that happen and then
he'll articulate them in a certain way
and he'll kind of draw it all together
um it's it's a real gift actually
awesome well um let's latita thank you
so much it's been a pleasure
thanks for having me